joining us right now is dr ashish ja
dean of brown university's school of
public health good morning how are you
doing
good morning i'm well how are you
good good thank you for joining us now
that christmas is behind us what are
your concerns with families gathering
family and friends gathering for the new
years
yeah you know obviously a lot of
infection happening around the country
what i'm worried about is uh people
basically not being careful at this
moment i do think it's safe for people
to gather
but the best way to do it is make sure
everybody's vaccinated at least all the
adults are uh and then use rapid tests
if you can get them that combination
makes it much much safer
i'm worried about people not only not
doing that but i'm also worried about
large gatherings which are just very
difficult to pull off right now without
causing a super spreader event so doable
together but you got to be careful
you know i live in los angeles i
recently worked in washington dc i'm now
here in new york city you see these long
lines around blocks of people trying to
get tests what do we need to do to
improve the testing situation
yeah first of all this is not where we
should be two years into the pandemic
i really think we have not done enough
to set up a testing infrastructure our
country needs and
i'm disappointed by that
what do we need to do first of all we
need to ramp up our ability to get those
rapid tests out i was happy to see the
president uh say that we're going to
have 500 million tests available to
americans in january obviously we all
wish it had come in december it would
have made an enormous difference
we also just have to have these tests
get cheaper over time i think that they
should be widely available at this point
in the pandemic we should not be at a
point where it's hard to get a test
dr zha omicron is leading to so many
breakthrough cases what should people
know or what should we be telling folks
who are already vaccinated and those who
even have their boosters
yeah this is what's really striking at
this moment is we are seeing
breakthrough infections at pretty high
numbers unless if you're boosted but
even among the boosted the good news is
if you're vaccinated and particularly if
you're boosted the infections tend to be
very very mild and this tends to be more
like a bad cold
so what i would say to folks who are
vaccinated and boosted is try to be
careful avoid getting infected but if
you do you're not going to end up
getting particularly sick the real
problem is the fact that there's still a
lot of americans who are unvaccinated
and when they get infected unfortunately
they're really ending up in the hospital
at much much higher rates and that's
what we have to pay attention to dr
what is your view on the current
isolation guidelines do you think we
need an overhaul
i do you know i understand the 10 days
from the cdc
but i think that that's probably too
long for vaccinated it's particularly
boosted people
i what my
my theory has or my sort of prescription
in on this has been that it should be
shorter it should be five days followed
with a negative antigen test so not just
five days alone because some people are
still contagious after five days but
five days followed with a test that's
negative
should be pretty reasonable for letting
people stop isolation
i do have a question about those antigen
tests i've heard that sometimes you have
to take multiple tests in order to get a
result
you know most of the times you should
not i mean again if you don't obviously
there's uh how well you do the test but
they're pretty straightforward to use
they tell you whether you're contagious
at that moment so if you're gonna go
visit someone you may want to do serial
tests to make sure you don't get you
don't pick up the infection or turn
positive over time uh but they work
pretty well
that makes sense doctors you saw thank
you so much